je m'appelle denis brunel g60 et 13 ans
bientôt 74
je suis de trois-rivières et je
travaille pour la banque nationale à
chenilles and most heureuse que ce
travail ne pas savoir comment moi si
c'est un plaisir pour moi c'est une
passion c'est première des choses c'est
pour contrer l'isolément pour me garder
le physique et le mental en forme comme
j'ai toujours été pour que ce soit
active que je n'avais pas du tout je
vous vous dis franchement les faits
c'est que je connais pas son nom un jour
peut-être que je pourrai plus travailler
mais j'espère que vous êtes assez loin
mais si je me dis c'est lisse et les
personnes âgées qui ont bâti de québec
ont pas dû mais garde c'est comme un
conte le début c'est comme son état dé
rester maître walter ne pas de destin